[Música]
llegamos al momento de revisar toda la
prensa internacional y nos acompaña
marta moya marta bienvenida muy buena
mañana de martes abrimos entonces esta
revista de prensa marta con la cobertura
de toda la prensa internacional frente a
la más posible encuentro entre el
presidente chino xi jinping y su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin que está
previsto que se reúnan en la cumbre de
la organización de cooperación de
shanghai en un pequeño en uzbekistán a
finales de esta semana hacia raúl buenos
días el south south china morning post'
abre el lunes abre el martes destacando
esta reunión de alto rango entre el
presidente si jinping y el presidente
ruso vladimir putin que sé que se
reunirán previsiblemente a finales de
esta semana dicen pues que es la primera
reunión entre ambos desde la pandemia y
por supuesto desde el inicio de la
invasión rusa dice pues que el viaje de
xi jinping empezará el miércoles entre
kazajistán y uzbekistán y pues
probablemente concluirá el viernes en
ese encuentro en esta organización de
cooperación en shanghai que es la
agencia denver marta bloomberg destaca
una reunión entre los altos diplomáticos
chinos y rusos el lunes en beijing y
dice que ambas naciones estarían
dispuestas a construir un orden mundial
más justo y más estable y destaca pues
que este es como decíamos el primer
encuentro entre ambos presidentes y que
pues que rusia sea china perdón se ha
mantenido de perfil un poco durante la
invasión rusa y que ahora pues aunque no
ha condenado explícitamente al régimen
de putin tampoco pues se ha privado ha
puesto palos en las ruedas a
proporcionar sanciones y dice pues que
las importaciones chinas han sido un
alivio para putin en este bueno pues en
estos más de seis meses de la guerra
vamos a ver ahora dos visiones marta la
estadounidense y la china pero empezamos
con el cero unidense con fox news así es
foxnews un medio pues muy a la derecha
en eeuu también destaca este encuentro
entre los líderes y dice pues que eeuu
tienen que hacer diplomacia que es lo
que ha venido haciendo como para que
rusia esa china no tome el ejemplo de
rusia con la invasión a ucrania
mismo con taiwán dice que ambas naciones
tienen pocos amigos en occidente y que
son pues los firmes opositores al poder
el 'global times' el 'global times' al
contrario un medio muy alineado al
partido comunista chino destaca pues la
sede de este encuentro no de la
organización de cooperación de shanghai
y dice pues que no es como la otan y que
la organización de cooperación de
shanghai no tiene pues estos
no tiene estos tintes de protección como
tiene la otan defensivos que será un
encuentro de 15 jefes de estado y que
bueno destaca pues este este entorno en
el que se va a dar la reunión el próximo
15 y 16 de septiembre que por supuesto
lo vamos a llevar aquí todas las
incidencias de esta reunión en revista
de prensa y claro que nuestros
informativos en france 24 cambiamos de
tema ahora marta porque la
contraofensiva ucraniana las últimas
jornadas y el repliegue todas las tropas
rusas en zonas estratégicas en el sur y
en el noreste del país también está
reflejando en toda la prensa
internacional concretamente el día de
hoy martes en washington posee buena
columna de opinión
en el que habla de cómo se redefinen
estas fuerzas entre putting selenski así
es es un artículo de opinión de david
ignatius un experto de política
internacional del 'washington post' que
dice pues que la contraofensiva
ucraniana hace cambiar un poco la
ecuación de los dos líderes de vladimir
putin y de volodymyr selenski dice que
cell en sí pues es un héroe poco
probable que al final pues se
unió a la sociedad ucraniana en torno a
una defensa de su pueblo y planea una
estrategia defensiva pues muy exitosa y
que bueno pues en sus deseos está
liberar a ucrania pero dice este
artículo opinión que eso todavía es un
deseo poco realista y dice que debería
impulsar la vía diplomática aunque los
rusos pues se quieran o no estén de
acuerdo con esa opinión porque ahora
selenski pues tiene la sartén por el
mango dice además de putin pues que es
el perdedor del último asalto y así es
el hombre que nunca pierde entonces pues
que él quería crear una guerra de salón
para que los rusos vieran por la tele
como pues iban avanzando en ucrania pero
pues que hasta los más fieles del
kremlin ahora sostienen que esto ha sido
una gran pérdida la contraofensiva
ucraniana de los últimos días bueno
marta gracias a por toda la información